alors justement maurice parlant de
l'évolution de l'utiliser il avait deux
films en 84 or quand vous décider pour
nous ici sur le plateau il a une
cigarette sinistrés m'arrivera encore
que pas distraction je lui mets ça se
gâte
ça vous un petit peu embêté dû enlever
sa cigarette absolument parce que ça
faisait partie des clichés que j'essaye
de parodier dans ma bande we go je me
souviens gary cooper quand il avait un
moment il se rouler une cigarette et
c'est ça que j'ai voulu faire j'étais
réellement embêté mais enfin c'est vrai
que l'organisation mondiale de la santé
à genève m'a redonné belle médaille pour
me récompenser de l'avoir enlevée donc
on va oublier ce fait ça aujourd'hui
ici un peu dévergondée également lucky
luke auparavant quand il rentrait dans
un saloon ya 50 ans il y avait jamais
une jeune fille là elles sont plutôt pas
mal oui quand je travaillais pour le
journal de spirou qui étaient destinés
aux enfants sur 10 ans il n'était pas
question
en général c'est les femmes étaient un
sujet qu'il fallait éviter c'est ce
qu'on me disait mais quand j'ai jeu j'ai
changé de journal et que j'ai travaillé
pour pilotes alors là on va me permettre
un peu plus alors lucky luke 50 ans mais
qui région les daltons exactement les
préférés du public ça fait 45 ans que
les signes que j'ai dessiné pendant ces
45 ans ils ont raté toutes leurs
attaques de banques de diligence ou de
train mais il ya une chose qu'ils n'ont
pas qu'ils n'ont pas raté c'est quand
même qu'ils ont amusé des millions et
des millions de lecteurs à travers le
monde entier la petite et grande des
riches et des pauvres alors 16 ans tu en
prends rendez vous pour le 50 ans dans
cinquante ans que j'ai dans cinq ans on
prend rendez vous pour les 50 ans et
dalton et rantanplan lui qu'en est il né
cette heure un peu plus tard c'était un
vieux souvenir que j'avais de d'un chien
très intelligent qui s'appelait
rintintin au cinéma et j'ai trouvé plus
amusant évidemment de prendre le
contre-pied de faire le chat le plus
bête de l'ouest alors vous avez une
certaine insolence par rapport à tintin
qui était un dessin je veux dire d'une
école plus plus réaliste vous cultivez
c'est un seul on serait ce que vous
lisez la bd moderne celle qui est
peut-être avec un moins d'humour
si j'essaye de me tenir au courant mais
il ya tellement de choses qui publics
ont publiquement on ne peut pas tout
lire
mais si vous appréciez
c'est certainement parce que quand on
dit que maurice débute avec franquin qui
le travaille avec goscinny pour
présenter une image de la bd et ils vous
respectent tous ces jeunes insolents
d'aujourd'hui pas tellement j'en vois
défiler pas mal chez moi et pour me
demander conseil mais de moins en moins
d'ailleurs je suppose qu'ils me
considèrent de plus en plus comme un
vieux routier qui ne peut plus il faut
plus qu'on peut plus faire comme moi
comment travaillez-vous quand même vous
donner un exemple de comment
travaillez-vous les idées s'ils
n'arrivent donc vous travaillez avec des
co auteurs parce que vous suscitez les
idées vous dessinez ensuite comment ça
ce matin que je travaillais avec
goscinny je fournissais toujours le
sujet je crée le personnage nécessaire
et je fournissais la la documentation
parce que goscinny n'avait rien comme
documentation mais maintenant c'est un
peu différent bien souvent le scénariste
john le sujet qu'ils préfèrent et si
chamarand viol accepte mais sacré de
toute façon il faut collaboré au
scénario on peut passer revirement
dessiner ce que ce que quelqu'un d'autre
vous donne donc on est toujours du
plaisir 50 ans après à faire vivre lucky
luke oui oui c'est un plaisir de
raconter une histoire en images
et ça c'est ça qui me passionne mais je
n'ai pas envie d'arrêter
alors je suis quand même un petit secret
si vous avez vous un petit peu plus de
50 ans et ma foi levé ça doit être un
beau élixir de jouvence parce que rabin
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas allez vous
allez 74 ans je le vis merci mon regard
des visites et longue vie à lucky luke
dont le dernier album vient de sortir on
le voit là ok corral et je crois qu'il a
déjà en préparation donc oui j'ai déjà
commencé à suivre
merci morice 40 avec nous jusqu'à la fin
de ce journal le temps d'apprendre